[Music]  there's only one way out you're gonna  tell your family members right now what  you've been afraid to say or the snakes  will be released in 10 seconds believe  me we will release this out of them I've  got the control right here you know when  you went to New York and you are an  escort what the are you talking well  tell me escorted some of these rock  bands okay I've never said that two of  my life I don't know what you're talking  about Parker do you think I tell my dad  I would like everyone to know I'm not  escort nor have I ever been Brandi you  said that no I never did you're  believing that you read I'm just hopin  I'll be to be my father well I  [Music]